for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university calm thank you and enjoy now
we're going to get into the actual
pathways of degrading the amino acids
and their carbon skeletons to each of
those key products and we'll start off
with the amino acids degraded
specifically to pyruvate so how many
amino acids have their carbon skeleton
degraded directly to pyruvate there are
six of them and they are draining that's
one glycine that's to Serie three
tryptophan for alanine five and cysteine
six okay okay so let's see how this
works so threonine actually with its the
major pathway by it
by which is degraded yield sucks in
Ocoee it and that's something we'll
actually see in another video because
sucks no Kelly is one of the key
products and that that pathway is the
major pathway but here in the minor
pathway via threonine dehydrogenase the
threonine can be converted into two
amino 3 ki W - right where we're
basically just oxidizing this carbon
right here the purple one there to the
carbonyl and in that process we make an
NADH okay so this is the minor pathway
about which three any integrated okay so
we get this two amino 3 Kido butyrate
and in this next reaction that two amino
3qw de-rate we add a coenzyme a and that
coenzyme a gets stuck right here with
the test right there to make it so that
this portion comes off as an acetyl co a
that we see here so two of those carbons
go that way and the rest of the molecule
up here ends up becoming glycine that
becomes glycine there
so now we've got glycine and glycine can
go a number of directions notice he's
got an arrow coming out of it here and
here and also here so let's go and since
this is this is a video on degrading the
amino acids to pyruvate let's go down
this way first and we'll show the other
pathways later
so glycine can be turned into serine but
we need to add a carbon to do that we
have a two carbon molecule here and
glycine and a three carbon molecule here
in serine so how do we do that we need a
carbon from somewhere well we're gonna
get a carbon from a from n five and ten
methylene tetrahydrofolate so the carbon
is coming in as a methylene group so
here this t methylene THF here this n 5
and 10 methylene THF is their one carbon
donor and it's going to add that one
carbon notice I've got that in orange
there it's going to add this orange
carbon here okay to get that hydroxy
methyl group there and so this ends on
the enzyme that catalyzes this reaction
is serine hydroxymethyl transformation
and that would be familiar if you watch
the video on one carbon transfer
conversions for tetrahydrofolate so I
suggest that you watch that video and
that series really if you haven't
already
just before you continue watching this
series so that gives us serine okay that
serine can undergo the serine
dehydratase reaction to basically get
rid of this o age group and the amino
group here and the alpha hydrogen and
that gives us pyruvate okay so we're
good
as far as threonine glycine and serine
giving rise to pyruvate okay now
tryptophan over here to the left
it's got 11 carbons so we wouldn't
really think about something that that
big giving rise to pyruvate but it does
because it's split kind of where this
red line is here to into a top portion
and that bottom portion of the molecule
and this top portion ends up
in alanine down here and we'll get to
that in just a second and this other
portion goes elsewhere as we will see
later goes elsewhere okay so and the
splitting of that Evette cipta fan is
occurs in multiple steps but the point
is that this portion up here like I said
ends up its alanine and so that alanine
these three carbons and really this
whole portion came from tryptophan and
alanine is the Alpha amino acid version
of the alpha keto acid that is pyruvate
and so in order to turn this alpha amino
acid into this alpha keto acid all we
need is a transamination reaction
catalyzed by alanine aminotransferase
and of course will require a pyro
paradox with phosphate as a cofactor and
the amino group just ends up attached to
alpha Q bitter right producing glutamate
and since that amino group is now gone
we end up with pyruvate so the carbons
in the tryptophan ended up in alanine
and and eventually in pyruvate okay so
that covers nearly all of you amino
acids giving rise to pyruvate the last
one is cysteine here and you'll notice
they're very similar in structure all
you really need to do is get rid of this
style group and this amino group and
you've got pyruvate so and this could
occur via sever up at several potential
paths but basically you just got to
remove the the thigh all group and then
remove the the amino group as an NH 4
plus and you'll end up with pyruvate
okay so that's pretty much it as far as
the amino acids giving rise to pyruvate
I do want to go back up though and talk
a little bit about the other other
places that glycine can go so glycine
can also be turned into glyoxylate over
here in this D amino acid oxidase
reaction so we're gonna oxidize that
this carbon right here of glycine
oxidative deamination here we're
removing this this amino group and we're
oxidizing that carbon as well so it's an
oxidative deamination to give glyoxylate
and by oxalate can be further oxidized
to oxalate by hepatic lactate
dehydrogenase okay that's that's an
alternative pathway for a glycine to go
go through glycine can also be cleaved
will have an gonna have an oxidative
cleavage by gleich glycine cleavage
enzyme what it'll do is they'll
basically take this carboxyl group of
glycine and it'll be cut off as a carbon
dioxide and the the amino group will
also come off with the alpha hydrogen as
an ammonium ion and that process can
give us an NADH which of course can be
used for energy and the this carbon this
carbon can be tacked on to THF to
produce and five-and-ten methylene THF
which can be used to supply one carbon
transfer reactions okay so that enzyme
that would catalyze that reaction is
glycine cleavage enzyme but could also
be called it's also called glycine
synthase if the reaction is run in the
reverse okay going from these guys and
this methylene back towards glycine okay
all right so that was kind of an aside
but that's basically how all these amino
acids can give rise to pyruvate and of
course pyruvate can then go through the
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex and
eventually through the TCA cycle we can
get a bunch of nadh fadh2 some GTP's and
of course that's all energy okay I hope
that video is helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying